Oh
initially I think it will be leadership
will come from the corporate community
as I mentioned there's already 15 or 20
companies admittedly a very few but
interest is is high I haven't met a
single company that I talked to that
thinks it's a bad idea I'm not sure they
are ready to do it or they want to be
leaders so I think the first step that
we'll see is leading companies in the
corporate community starting to issue
integrated reports that will get
visibility they will be seen as as
developing the new best practices I
think closely related to that is the
large pension funds which we were
talking about encouraging companies to
do so even putting pressure on companies
to do so the NGO community the
stakeholder community when I did the
research from my book I wasn't sure if
they would support integrated reporting
or they wanted to continue to have
separate sustainability reports they're
very supportive of this and so I think
you'll see the NGOs that have been
putting pressure on companies for
separate sustainability reporting
starting to call for integrated
reporting but ultimately just to be
clear I think this needs to be done by
regulation I don't think it should be
done immediately I think we need time to
experiment learn what's involved but if
you're going to have a sustainable
society virtually all your companies
need to be framing what they're doing in
terms of a sustainable strategy with
integrated reporting being a key tool
for that it's not a silver bullet that
alone won't do it but it is certainly a
key tool for doing that and I would see
that happening initially country by
country it could be required by the SEC
here suggesting that companies provide
non-financial information in the MD&A
because that's under the regulatory
authority of the SEC it has already
happened in South Africa through King
three Mervyn King very well known
corporate governance expert you probably
know produced a report calling for
integrated reporting every listed
company on the Johannesburg Stock
Exchange starting July 1st has to
produce an integrated report the French
National Assembly is voting on this in
May I'm told
I'm not fluent in French so I haven't
been able to check that out myself the
Prince of Wales accounting for
sustainability project is in the process
of organizing an international
integrated reporting committee it will
have a steering committee a working
group represented on the steering
committee will be all the big accounting
firms major corporations corporate
groups NGOs investor investor groups
that will clearly create a lot of
visibility's so what I think will happen
over the next year is that awareness
will grow understanding will grow about
integrated reporting more and more
companies will practice it more and more
investors and stakeholders will
encourage it and I can't predict the
future four years five years from now
you'll start to see legislation on a
country-by-country basis and I'm
guessing I'm hoping that a decade from
now this will be the required practice
all over the world